the following conversation is with
darius dale the ceo and founder of 42
macro in this conversation we spend all
of our time talking about inflation the
federal reserve and what you should
expect moving forward these
conversations are brought to you by ftx
us you can click on the link in the
description to learn more
i hope that you enjoyed this
conversation with darius and learn just
as much as i did let's get into it
darius
dale how are you my friend
what's up bud how you doing today i'm
doing pretty well minus the 9.1 percent
inflation that they are dealing with in
the united states of america
well it's actually 11 if you look at it
on a three-month annualized basis but
who's counting
let's start there
9.1 is the june 2022 cpi data uh you say
11 explain the difference
yeah so uh if you look at on a
year-over-year rate of change basis so
like june of 2012 uh the taking of the
percentage change from june to 21 you'd
get wind up at 9.1 percent but the more
concerning issue is that we continue to
accelerate on a trending basis so
looking at on a three-month annualized
percentage change basis uh we actually
came in at 10.6
so the time series continues to move
away from the fed's target and pushing
us into a direction of more and more uh
tightening um this report was a disaster
across the board from the perspective of
anybody who is anticipating on inflation
a returning back towards chen on any
reasonable time frame or b anticipating
a sort of uh what we've been talking
about on the program or federal reserve
ambulance sirens anytime soon so when
you see that why do they use the uh
9.1 percent the 12-month year-over-year
versus the month uh annualized is it
because the 12 month looks better or is
there some other argument
well no the so it's traditionally how
you want to calculate um in a sort of
time series for the most part you know
particularly inflation you want to look
at it on a 12 year over year basis you
know kind of take removes all the
seasonality that tends to be associated
with different cycles in the economy
housing consumer cycles et cetera et
cetera and so that's the cleanest read
on a time series um you know for
something like inflation the problem is
for covet we've had so many fits and
starts as it relates to the different
variants and the proliferation they're
in that it's been ver the time series on
a year over year rate of change basis
has been noisy and to to a degree uh
these inflation statistics are being
flattered by some of the sort of advent
of delta that we saw kind of the
beginning of delta that we saw in the
summer of last year but again
that's not the issue the issue is that
it actually is accelerating sequentially
now if you look at it over the last
three months and annualize that
percentage change inflation on the
headline basis is coming in at 10.6
percent um that's the fastest number
we've seen in a few months but more
importantly things like core inflation
re-accelerating to you know where we at
um six point or seven point seven
percent on a three-month annualized
basis and my two favorite statistics
something we've been talking about
literally all year on the program are
median cpi and sticky cpi so median cpi
what's the rate of change of all the
different um different components of the
entire cpi basket there's hundreds of
components that is accelerating to seven
point four percent on a three-month
annualized basis which means the median
three-month annualized rate of change of
every single thing in the inflation
basket as it is growing at a rate of
seven point four percent and then if you
look at isolate the variables that are
most sticky that tend to have to tend to
be less responsive to changes in the
economy that tend to have prices move in
a much more auto correlated gradual
fashion uh that is running at seven
point six percent on a three-month
annualized basis that is a 40-year high
for that particular time series when you
start to look at this uh we saw the
federal reserve in november and december
talk tough in 2022 they started to raise
interest rates and they've gotten more
and more aggressive they claim that
they're going to do quantitative
tightening and start selling assets off
their balance sheet uh while they're
doing that and interest rates are going
up inflation is accelerating as well
both on a year-over-year basis but also
this three-month annualized basis
why is that happening and
does this mean in july we're just
getting a big fat one percent interest
rate hike and they're going to try to
bring the big boy weapons to the war now
yeah so i mean i think one thing that's
uh so yeah to answer your question i
think 100 basis points of a rate hike is
very much on the table for the feds uh
july 27th fomc meeting i think the
bigger issue is
do they stay at this this pace right
because right now the fed is operating
currently under a framework that says
our star the neutral rate of of the
neutral um interest rate the interest
rate that you know sort of that causes
the economy to neither accelerate nor
decelerate is somewhere around two and a
half percent at least that's what powell
said their estimates were the
committee's estimates were uh going back
to last uh that last fomc meeting on the
june 15th
uh we might start to get to a process
whereby the fed
looking at the data is sort of saying
hey look our policy is being really
ineffective in terms of moving the
needle on inflation maybe we have to
revise up our expectations of our star
and then we actually have to start
speeding up the pace of tightening
that's something certainly something
that has not happened yet and very much
could happen if inflation continues to
surprise the upside in the coming months
you've got a couple of charts here the
first is u.s headline cpi energy and
agriculture can't crash fast enough
explain why you think that
yeah so we've seen uh so commodity
prices if you look at industrial metals
energy agricultural prices energy prices
etc are really starting to decline i
mean if you look at it on an index basis
you know industrial metals are off
somewhere around 30 off their highs
agricultural energy around off 20 plus
percent off their highs but as you can
see in the food and energy price
inflation you know we accelerated to
12.2 percent on food we just climbed uh
to 35 percent on a three-month
annualized basis for energy but
obviously 35 is not a reasonable number
if you're trying to get inflation under
control and that's my point is that it's
going to take time for the moves in
commodity markets to be reflected in
inflation statistics it could take
several months before those kinds of
moves are actually you know adequately
pushing inflation statistics down so
that that's the first chart that's kind
of the first key takeaway there is that
we might have to go through some more
pain over a number of months before we
actually see those declines reflected in
the statistics
when you look at this next chart that we
have here you've got that both goods and
service prices are melting up explain
this
yeah so this is uh goes back to
something we talked about er this winter
we were like hey look there's the the
goods disinflation is likely to become
the driver of of course cpi and for a
moment there it was causing core cpi to
slow because we saw sort of the unline
of supply chain disruptions uh we saw
sort of consumer shift they're
purchasing uh the dominance of the
purchasing from goods to services that's
something that's happened on the first
half of this year as well um if you look
at the sort of the rate of change
between goods and services about a nine
to ten that about a thousand basis
points of a difference between the
growth rate of service consumption and
the growth rate of goods consumption so
that costs for a brief moment in time
core inflationary pressures to back off
because goods was moving down faster
than services was going up well now you
got both of them going up simultaneously
if you look at it again i mentioned
goods uh goods uh core goods inflation
was at six point six percent core
services inflation at eight point two
percent you know those two numbers are
moving away from the actual
year-over-year time series which tells
you that we're still building momentum
uh to the upside and core inflationary
pressures and this is exactly what you
would expect inflation is a lagging
indicator to the broader economic cycle
and you typically see core inflationary
pressures peter out last as you head
into uh start and and sort of middle
parts of a recession
you've got leading indicators or
rocketing past the moon which is just an
all-time title for a slide what does
this say
thank you just to borrow some uh some
crypto lingos let's let the kids know
that i'm still hip uh anyway um so what
we're showing here in this chart is i
mentioned uh the first set of bars uh
the great by the way is explaining these
bars the three the gray bar just shows
the the prior month's three month
annualized rate of change and the blue
bars the most recent months of june um
as you can see we're moving in the wrong
direction if we're trying to get core pc
down right median cpi again the median
of everything in the inflation basket is
now accelerating at a three point or at
a seven
seven point four percent annualized rate
of change that's the highest three-month
range annualized rate of change we've
ever seen in median cpi as time series
goes back to the early eighties um if
you look at it the atlanta fed's got a
sticky cpi as i mentioned earlier um
that that basket is accelerating at 7.6
on a three-month annualized basis the
fastest part we've seen since august of
1982. neither you nor i nor john were
born in august of 1982 so the feds got a
real serious inflation problem on their
hands and and what i mean by that is
that those two time series are very
highly correlated to the third set of
bars which is core pce which is the
fed's preferred inflation metric so
that's obviously an issue
when you look at this last one
overheating by double wha what is this
showing us
yeah so
this goes back to why i believe the fed
is very likely to remain very aggressive
um they're they're the likely the sort
of the there's a distribution of policy
outcomes right the market is always
pricing in some probability of of xyz
are happening across the curve you know
25 basis point hike 50 basis point 975
base playing high now we're having a
legitimate discussion about 100 bases
point hike which i'm not sure has ever
happened in the us maybe it has but
certainly not in recent in recent years
probably paul broker i would imagine uh
gave us quite a few of those but anyway
so when the fed looks at the economy it
looks at the economy through two lands
it looks at everything through three
lanes one financial stability that's
kind of taking a backseat for now number
two the inflation that's obviously the
dominant driver of policy and it has
been and will likely continue to be the
dominant driver of fed policy for the
medium term but then there's also the
labor market and so when the fed looks
at the labor market they see a labor
market that is truly in and
realistically overheating by a double
and what i mean by that is unpacking
this chart the light blue bar show the
sort of the the the trend annual
three-month annualized rate of change in
the 2015 in the five years that ended
2019. so it's sort of like hey how do we
trend it just you know across you know
multiple years in cycles and swings in
the economy what's sort of the baseline
rate of change that's the blue bars and
this the gray bars just showed the
previous month and then the dark blue
bars show um the most recent month and
as you can see from a private payrolls
perspective that's private employment uh
total total uh total non-farm tables in
the private sector you know we're
growing it at basically double the rate
that we've grew at in the in the um in
the pre-crisis uh in the pre-pandemic uh
trend um if you look at the second
clustering of bars which is
average hourly earnings you know that
that three-month annualized rate of
change the dark blue bars double what
we're seeing uh relative to the light
blue bar which again was our baseline
trend baseline prior to the pandemic and
then you take your eyes over to the far
set of bars which is kind of the real
kind of tea take away that tells the fat
they need to keep their foot very much
firmly pressed on the break here
if you look at private uh sort of
aggregate income growth for the private
sector when you prioritize all those
three uh different um different
variables between uh total payroll
employment average hourly earnings and
average uh hours worked you know we're
running at eight percent in as a through
the june of jobs report that's basically
a double relative to where our trend
rate of aggregate private sector income
grew at uh in the 2015 and 2019 uh time
frame so
in our estimation the federal reserve
the the thousands of wonky phd
economists are doing research just like
we are doing are looking at the labor
market and saying it's giving them like
four thumbs up you know it's the rick
james like i wish i had more hands
they're getting four thumbs up to keep
hiking rates to keep doing very
aggressive quantitative tightening until
they are confirmed that they have broken
something and they have not confirmed
they've broken anything yet we've seen
people like jamie dimon and jp morgan
they continue to say hey there's a very
complex situation at play very
unprecedented we don't know what's going
to happen they pause share buybacks
they are also kind of
strengthening their balance sheet in
preparation for potentially
more issues in their loan book but at
the same time we see the morgan stanley
ceo saying that a deep and severe
recession is unlikely in the united
states
what do you think most of the major
players these people have so much
information at their fingertips they
have these massive you know teams of
analysts
why are they so confident or seem to be
uh so sure that we aren't going to head
to very very bad economic times given
the aggressiveness that it appears the
fed is going to have to pursue in
interest rate hikes to get this
inflation down
well let's let's be honest here right
like jamie dimon is the head of a major
uh multi major uf bank major
multinational corporation you know he's
not going to go out and spook all of his
clients and tell them to do very you
know aggressive things like withdraw
capital et cetera et cetera and
basically shut down the financial sector
so he's not incentivized to tell people
how bad it's likely to be and quite
frankly i'm not sure he knows right at
the end of the day i don't think anyone
knows the real depth and magnitude of
the recession we're likely to enter at
some point over the medium term because
the reality is you know a lot a lot of
non-linear things tend to happen in
recession that either make it better or
worse right like what if we're in
recession in q4 and then russia decides
to cut off all the gas to europe europe
goes into a great depression and makes
our terms of trade significantly worse
and obviously corporate earnings et
cetera get significantly worse or you
know what if china has a banking crisis
which is something that's making the
rumors and rounds uh in recent days uh
you know there's a lot of things that
happen when growth is slowing and
liquidity is tightening and so the
reality is i don't think anyone truly
knows but going back to the fed
the fed wants a mild recession they
won't tell you that but we've done a
tremendous amount of work i think as
much work as anybody i've seen
in terms of quantifying the impact of
recessions on things like labor
corporate profits the market itself and
more importantly inflation and when you
look at it from an inflation perspective
it's not really clear that there is a
you know statistically significant
relationship between the size of
recessions and the drawdown we typically
see in the fed's preferred inflation
metric which is called pce inflation and
so the fed but the one thing we do know
is that you do need to get a recession
to to experience a drawdown of some sort
um and the reality is i think the fed is
well aware of that again if i can sit in
here
just a guy in a room and figure that out
certainly the thousands of pg economists
at the federal reserve can figure that
out as well and so ultimately again
they're not going to tell you they'd
like a mild recession but the reality is
they're not going to get inflation down
without it
we recently saw vladimir putin he was in
like a meeting and he was talking about
uh essentially claiming checkmate on the
global economy and he was saying that uh
when russia invaded ukraine
that was the end of the us dollar
dominance on a global basis and we now
are headed towards a multi-polar world
and i'm always careful to point out
i don't agree with most of what he's
probably done uh and i no way do i want
to seem supportive of that specific
individual or his actions but i do think
that time and again he has continued to
talk about the macro economy in a way
that appears to be more honest or a
different viewpoint than what we hear in
the mainstream media in the united
states of america and so his argument
was the financial sanctions prove to the
world that you have to be friends with
the us in order to continue to be uh
using the u.s dollar system right or
they could kick you out freeze you take
your foreign reserves all this stuff
how much do the sanctions specifically
play into the inflation that we're
seeing because we're now a couple of
months after right there was this talk
uh maybe back in like march i think is
when we first heard the biden
administration say you know putin gas
hike and the sanctions and and kind of
the actions
but they had only invaded in like the
end of february so it was unlikely that
you were really going to get kind of
price impact for something that only
existed for two weeks
now
we're three four five months later
it feels like now actually there could
be price impact
but i don't know how to think about that
like how do you think through
sanctions
geopolitical conflict and then like we
have this super high inflation how do
you unpack how much of it is
contributing to the inflation
oh that's a loaded question my friend uh
so i'll try to
address the various components so
you talked about sanctions like one i
think you and i spoke about this in
recent episodes which is you know when
you go back and look at where inflation
was in january of 22 uh you know prior
to russia it's crossing one border
ukraine you know we were at 7.5 percent
and now we're at 76 or 9.1 percent again
year over year for the month of june so
if you assume russia added all that
inflation you know maybe they've added
you know let's call it 260 basis points
of inflation um that's sorry how much
baseball is inflation that's that's
that's
that's obviously russia has not caused
all that inflation so there very clearly
is a legitimate inflation problem in the
u.s economy again we just spent five
minutes talking about how the labor
market is overheating by a double that
is generating a for lack of a better
word a crap ton of inflation um
domestically and that's further
supported by uh core services inflation
being at eight percent russia has very
little to do with our services inflation
our housing bubble that the fed and the
fiscal government um before effectively
uh created in the pandemic era um but
going back to the sort of um you know
the specific impact of inflation i think
it's really difficult to sort of draw a
one-to-one like what these are very
dynamic like impossible to model
ecosystems right like one it's almost
like the butterfly effect to some degree
but one thing we can sort of do is sort
of a cross-sectional analysis to sort of
understand kind of the relative impact
of something like sanctions right we'll
never be able to know what the actual
true basis point amount of sanctions are
but we can look at something like
the spread between u.s inflation
relative to the rest of the developed
world's inflation and right now if you
factor in the most recent print we're
somewhere around uh you know 160 170
basis points higher than the rest of the
world's developed world the western
world's uh inflation rates um that's in
the 95th percentile of all readings
going back as far back as we can get the
data you know you know 50 60 70 years
and so it's telling you that there are
inflationary pressures in the u.s
economy that are very much separate and
apart from things like sanctions etc
which are obviously impacting everyone
at the same time
john what questions do you have
darius i'm curious about like we're
obviously heading into unprecedented
times no one really knows what's going
on what are people doing with liquidity
are people storing dry powder and then
how do you measure how much liquidity is
being dried up or in the market
currently
yeah great question john it's good to
see you man um so
to answer your question yes we are
seeing uh some storing of dry powder but
it's not necessarily um as a function of
of investment decision making right the
federal government through
six and a half let's call it six and a
half trillion dollars into the economy
uh through stimulus checks ppp etc etc
and so we saw a dramatic uptick uh in
the share uh in the ratio of sort of a
household cash and checkable deposit so
basically cash as a percent of overall
net worth that went from basically like
one percent to three percent so
households are much more capitalized
from a cash perspective liquidity
perspective than they have been in
recent cycles but the reality is um if
you look at you know still where the the
share of ownership for things like you
know stocks etc more risky assets those
are coming off all-time highs what's
suffered in that relationship in that
basket has obviously been the households
allocation of fixed income which has
been and continues to track at an
all-time low so but that's just only one
factor at one side of liquidity i mean
that's sort of the liquidity that'll be
used in the real economy in in in you
know the real economy the liquidity from
the perspective of the financial markets
the one that we care about the most as
investors if you look at sort of federal
reserve supply liquidity or net
liquidity from that uh channel and then
there's also the net liquidity it's
provided from uh the uh the fiscal
channel through the lens of the treasury
general account and we do the math on
this and i'll slow down when i say this
our math suggests we could see over 900
billion dollars of net liquidity drained
from now through your end
that's that's bigger than the entire
drainage of net liquidity we saw in the
sort of 21 months between you know kind
of mid-17 and mid-2019
as a function of quantity the previous
quantitative tightening program so we're
trying to squeeze more than 21 months of
qt
in through the pipe in like six months
the fed will break something i i'm
convinced about that i think it's pretty
clear at this point they're going to
break something if they try to do that
because again the markets don't know how
to digest that remove the size of that
removal of liquidity at such a such a
such a truncated period of time and it's
our expectation that that's going to
cause some problems uh this fall what
are the biggest losers when that happens
go find go go go to the riskiest part of
the spectrum
if you look at the uh the spectrum of
risks you know and those are the things
that get get destroyed when liquidity
dries up it dries up in the fringes
first and it just keeps drying up and
takes one asset class after another
until eventually it's it's getting close
to your beloved s p 500 um you know so
obviously we saw our friend kathy wood
and her um her narratives basically got
punted starting in q1 of last year um
and we've seen since seen various
sectors style factors small caps you
know cyclic high beta cyclicals etc uh
within the equity market all that stuff
has taken turns in terms of peaking i
mean you go back and look at the nasdaq
peaked in november and then finally the
s p 500 peaked in in january and so you
know when you talk about reduction in
liquidity you know with what's really
happening just from a technical
standpoint and i think this is important
to explain as well what the fed is doing
the vet is not selling bonds into the
market the fed is not dumb enough to do
that at least not
yet maybe maybe they will um but what
they're really doing is saying hey
we've been this gigantic buyer at least
on the secondary market but we all can
assume that it's basically the primary
market because the fed is controlling
the primary dealers they've been this
entire gigantic buyer of u.s treasuries
throughout the let's call it the last
few years
what they're doing is they're stepping
away and forcing us as investors as the
private sector to capitalize the us
government and the issue with that
process is
we generally run max invested as the
private sector you know you know maybe
you might not be fully invested but your
cash is someone else's uh you know sort
of um
your asset is someone else's liability
and so the reality is is that as a
federal reserve steps away to the tune
of let's call it 900 billion dollars
over the next six months we're gonna
have to capitalize that uh we're gonna
have to roll over u.s debt we're gonna
have to capitalize the incremental the
debt issues that they're doing to the
tune of 900 plus billion dollars and
that money's got to come from somewhere
it's going to come from you know it's
not going to you're not going to sell
bitcoin to buy a u.s treasury bond but
you think about this as a the cascading
process price of bitcoin goes down and
the prices small caps go down the price
s p goes down the price apple credit
goes down and eventually
people have enough liquidity uh that
they need to capitalize the government
because again it's at the top of the
global capital structure if it needs
money it's going to get money gotcha
so while we are recording this uh we've
got uh whaler from the fed is uh is
spouting off uh and i'm just gonna read
you a couple of the quotes that are uh
pretty incredible first yesterday's
inflation number was not a big surprise
what is your reaction to the fed members
now i mean
what
wait what we went from transitory last
year to we're expecting nine ten percent
inflation that that was quick uh i yeah
no i mean
look he chris waller and and um and john
and jim buller
first of all and jim buller both
formerly of the federal reserve uh bank
of st louis they probably do as much
data collection and analysis as anybody
out there you know they've been well out
front and expecting higher inflation
above target inflation surprises and
thus have been well out front and
leading their colleagues on the fomc to
getting to you know leading them to the
water that is higher interest rates and
more quantitative tightening so uh
perhaps it wasn't a surprise to him
because he's been sounding the alarm
bell all along like look you guys need
to hurry up this is getting worse and
worse and worse the issue with it as it
relates to the broader markets is that
you know that consensus is now starting
to become the moral outcome or sorry
that that that view is now becoming the
consensus modal outcome amongst fomc
persistence we saw uh cleveland fed's
loretta mester talk about the uh specter
100 basically rate hype set you wouldn't
rule it out mary daley who inherited you
know janet yellen's seat at the you know
the at the federal reserve bank of
saints uh san francisco which is
traditionally a very dovish leaning
branch is also signing off and she said
she's comfortable with 100 basis point
rate hike so i think chris waller is
effectively taking uh somewhat of a
career victory lap saying hey look i
told you so let's get going
a second quote
is that the market pricing for 100 basis
points is getting ahead of themselves
ooh for july back on that pushing back
okay that that that is that is an
incrementally diverse uh commentary
relative to where we were where we uh
closed yesterday and so if he's saying
the market's getting ahead of itself
what he's effectively saying is that hey
look we haven't gotten the boss to sign
off on this yet um you know that you
know what typically happens and this is
this is my own interpretation of how the
process works is uh whenever they need
to change their messaging fomc
they push whoever in who's ever the most
hawkish or the most dovish out of the
door and just to have them you know kind
of cast uh set off a cascading series of
commentary um and so perhaps
uh jerome powell is pushing mr wall out
of the door and say hey just tone it
down try to get the market to tone down
this this pricing 100 base play rate
hike perhaps the fed is not comfortable
with that uh but ultimately what you
know again whether or not we get 100
basis points or not is there really any
functional difference between 100 base
point rate hike and a 75 base plan rate
hike heading into recession are you
gonna go from selling risk assets to
buying risk assets since they only do
275 basis points no the rent obviously
the answer is no we don't really truly
understand the real you know linear
there's no real linear impact of
financial tightening on the economy we
just know when you tighten things get
worse and you ease things get better
that's about as good as we can do as
economists so i'm not particularly
phased by that but i do think it's
interesting relative to a fed that
seemed to be very sort of a acquiescent
to allowing the market to move them
towards uh incremental hawkish policy
but i guess it looks like they're
putting the line in the sand perhaps on
75 basis points they're trying last
thing is he says that he doesn't
necessarily see uh that the united
states has to suffer a recession and uh
he believes that unemployment
essentially have to explode higher in
order for that to occur do you think
that is the only metric uh that would
have to move for the recession to happen
and do you think that he is uh correct
in saying that uh we don't have to
suffer a recession if they keep doing
what they're doing
no so he he's he's dead wrong on that
again uh that slides 73 through 80 in
our july uh macro scouting report we
published that last friday i think we've
done a lot more work that he has on the
impact of recessions on inflation and to
answer this question you have to have a
recession to get inflation where they
are projecting it to be by the end of
next year the fed has a 2.7 core pc
forecast q4 for q4 for 2023 to get from
where we are at 4.7 in the most recent
month which might be going up actually
just based on this move we've seen in
core inflation measures particularly
median and sticky cpi we got to do a
hell of a lot of damage to the economy
particularly the labor economy in order
for that to occur in order to get core
pc down at 2.7 percent um so he's dead
wrong on that view and ultimately um you
know we think the markets are going to
have to be surprised by the reality that
hey look we need a recession in order to
get inflation down and once you get into
recessionary conditions you know it
becomes very non-linear as i mentioned
all sorts of things could happen that
can make it either better or worse and
the reality is we just have to be there
and be humble bayesians when that's
occurring as investors
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or learn more about 42
macro at this point if people aren't
subscribed to 42 macraf do you hear this
just absolute incredible articulation of
what's going on in the world i don't
know what you guys are doing but where
can we send people to check out more
i appreciate that that kind endorsed my
friend so 42macro.com is our website
come check it out we got a bunch of
sample research out there for you kind
of check out what you might like what
you don't like what might be helpful for
you and then if you can't afford it
that's uh it's all good we we do our
macro minute every day for for those of
you who have smaller budget smaller uh
trade and smaller size and then
definitely follow me on twitter at 42
macro d dale appreciate y'all you're
killing it man all right thank you very
much we'll see you next week i really
enjoyed that conversation with darius
every time i talked to him i learned
something new this episode was brought
to you by ftx us if you click on the
link in the description you can learn
more ftx has bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies with transaction fees
sometimes as much as 85 percent less
than their competitors they're also
testing out digital stocks which allow
you to trade bitcoin crypto and digital
stocks all from one location they won't
have any transaction fees on the stock
trading nor will they have any payment
for order flow go check it out today by
clicking on the link in the description
and i'll see you all with the next
interview